good evening uh members officers of the
council and members of the public uh
it's just gone seven so we'll start
um welcome to this meeting of governance
nordic committee i'm just going to go
through the usual housekeeping uh fire
evacuation procedure if the fire alarm
is activated please vacate the offices
via the stairs either through the
security door or opposite the lifts in
the foyer please do not use the lifts
please assemble in hawley square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise you when it is deemed safe to
return the chamber
does anyone intend to film the meeting
no great um any member of the
don't even need to say that bit that's
perfect
restriction on mobile phones would
everyone present please ensure your
mobile phone is turned to silent and
they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber while the
meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast on the
council's youtube channel
rule 21 would any member who wishes to
speak on the
council procedure rule 20.1 please
announce it now
great um i've got apologies for absence
um there's been apologies received from
councillor pew um has there any other
apologies uh to give
great
um declarations of interest are there
any declarations of interest
perfect
um
moving on to a gender item three minutes
of the meeting held on first of december
2021 to approve the minutes of the
meeting held on first december 21 copy
attached to the agenda but can i have a
proposer and a seconder
praise chair it's proposed by councillor
cup and seconded by councillor towning
unless i hear any objection i will take
these as approved
perfect uh we're going to move swiftly
on to item number four which is our
quarterly internal or date
quarterly or internal audit update
report from simon webb from the east
kent audit partnership who introduced
the report
thank you chair good evening members
um this is of course our quarterly
internal audit update report which
summarizes the work undertaken on your
behalf by the east kent audit
partnership since the last meeting of
this committee uh together with the
performance of the east kent audit
partnership to the 31st of december
if i could draw your attention to the
table on page 15 of the
agenda pack that summarizes the 10
reviews undertaken during this quarter
quite a busy
quarter with 10 reviews
we were pleased to report substantial
assurance in two fairly significant
areas of the council's operations those
being council tax and also the payment
of housing benefits
we concluded reasonable assurance in the
areas of playgrounds and also creditors
clearly creditors is an important area
of the council's operations in terms of
the amount of money that goes through
those systems and indeed feeds into the
council's main financial systems
we concluded limited assurance in two
areas those being equality and diversity
and also right to buy we do have
directors here this evening should
members have uh questions in relation to
those items the reasons for those
conclusions are detailed in the bullet
points on the page on pages 21-23
we concluded no assurance in the area of
street cleansing
and the reasons for that are summarized
in the bullet points
on page
24-26 of the agenda pack again we do
have directors here this evening to take
members questions on that and should you
have any
we undertook three further reviews where
um an assurance
opinion wasn't applicable they were gdpr
and particularly the impact of home
working on gdpr
in light of the
global pandemic
the other area was a position statement
in terms of the council's
controls to tackle climate change
and the final area uh was corkley
housing benefit testing this time um 21
22 quarters one and two
follow-up is a very important part of
internal audit work
about three foot to four months after
each audit review we go back to ensure
that the recommendations have been
implemented
um details of the follow-ups undertaken
in the quarter are on page 32 of the
agenda pack
and there were four follow-ups during
that period
we then have the annexes to the
report annex one shows progress against
the internal audit plan to the 31st of
december as at that time we'd completed
68.42
of your plan days slightly behind the
curve at 31st of december but i can
update that we were up to 85.25 percent
as that 28th of feb um so slightly ahead
of the target at that point of 83
so progressing well uh with the plan as
we move into the
final um
furlong of the year
um
also within the report you have the
definitions of the assurance levels and
the recommendations they're on page 38
of the pack
annex 3
on page 39 shows the
outstanding recommendations after
follow-up
and annex 4 on page 41 shows the limited
areas yet to be followed up they will be
progressed to this committee in the
forthcoming months
finally page 42 of the pack shows the
balanced scorecard of performance
indicators um for the esken audit
partnership uh probably the most
important one on there is the progress
against the plan
and as i indicated it was 68.42 at
december but up to 85 at the end of last
month
that concludes my presentation um chair
but obviously happy to take any
questions that members may have on any
of the items raised thank you
perfect thank you members do you have
any questions
uh councillor
ghana thank you
now i've got a few questions on a couple
of the areas so i'll run through them in
the order they
appear in the report rather than
necessarily priority order because it
might make it easier for me to do it
um on the the first couple of questions
i've got is around
um playgrounds which received a
reasonable
assurance
it's fine but there were one or two
areas improvement
that you identified
i just wanted confirmation i understand
the different tiers of inspections tiers
one
two and three for inspections
tier one weekly tier two quarterly and
tier three annually he confirmed that
all
all playgrounds in planet have been
subject to these
inspections over the last year
and um
if they have our of the reports
available publicly to
to view that's my first question so i go
for a couple and then
you can answer okay yes
inspections um
have also
wanted to just confirm that roster
inspections
are they the tier three inspections are
the same as the tier three inspections
and also if they all could be comp if
they're different if they'll be
completed for the year
uh 2021 and are they all publicly
available
um
and the last bullet in that section
uh around the funding structure
um i think it mentions that um
some playgrounds are found to be either
not set or not detailed either the
funding structure for those
is um
is
is there a link here with um
or no what i mean does that mean that
some playgrounds haven't got any funds
available for their upkeep or update
um and also
i think the other question was around
there's a mention of some
being transferred to parish councils i
mean i'm perishing town councils i'm
not aware of any
playgrounds
the only conversations being held around
playgrounds being transferred to
paris or town councils maybe is there
any more information you could give me
on that
if there is anything
any news on that please
so maybe if you just do the playgrounds
right now
thank you councillor i didn't know if um
mike um from an operational services
point of view you wanted to pick up on
those points and then i'll come back on
any outstanding audio areas if need be
yeah okay um
so i think that so the first point was
around the
tiers
so
the our internal team who are uh
qualified
they hold a
qualification for playground playground
uh inspection they undertake yeah they
undertake the internal inspections the
weekly the you know the quarterly
inspections we use a contractor so so
there's there's a roster inspection
annually on the on the playground so we
have an independent inspection annually
um so does that does that answer that
yeah so it was
sort of confirmation that all it's all
playgrounds are covered by that roster
inside
all playgrounds yeah so our team inspect
all the all playgrounds and then and
they receive a roster inspection
okay and and other are those reports
available to be viewed there
in general the reports are i mean the
reports are available um they're not
published uh with the exception of the
uh ethelbert crescent vikingship report
which is published on the website
currently
okay thanks yeah they i think the final
question was about um
transfer into parish and town councils i
hadn't i didn't know anything about any
being available for for transfer to
parish and town councils
um
so historically there have been
transfers uh i think the most recently
at westgate
um the the saint crispin's um wreck one
has been transferred to the to the town
council um uh that i don't believe
there's anything currently uh
you know in progress about about
transfer
okay thank you
um
i think the next one i wanted to ask
about
is
street cleansing
um i mean they're really
it's maybe
like a bit more of an explanation i
think
from
um
mike or gavin
about this complete divergence between
the lack of assurance a lack of ability
to provide a
um a review and any assurance at all
and
uh the statement which i've i've have
read through which sort of answers some
of the reasons for it and it it it
always seems like there's i could sort
of understand how a few points might be
raised
that um
that you might disagree with but this is
sort of
poles apart on one side
it's is total lack of any assurance and
on the other side
you're
i think should i say this very
disappointed about it maybe if you could
explain
some of the reasons behind why there's
no luxury and what what what what you're
gonna do so it's when we're here next
year
there is a
we get a report which um
says there's a reasonable if not better
assurance for our street cred thank you
okay thank you councillor um
i think that
yeah the first thing to say is uh there
is a there is an action plan in the uh
you know attached to the audit and
um i accept that though that there's
actions that need to be taken forward
and you know we will be progressing
those actions i think uh where we um
where i disagree with with with the
outcome of the audit is because it
doesn't
uh it's not reflective of the
um the work the very hard work that goes
on uh particularly the work through the
through the pandemic and you know the uh
level of street cleanliness that's out
uh that you know that that's exhibited
out there and yeah and the hard work of
the team and i think um you know there's
a lot of work that we are doing there's
there's we have a project for example on
um uh to
to bring forward the
um yeah the measurement of street
cleansing so it's so it's um
more transparent
um which which we're almost ready to go
live with and and various other things
with our
um
environmental operatives who are
responsible for doing sort of deep
cleansing uh you know graffiti removal
you know the the sort of the one-off
things that just make our local
environment better um
i think
you know the audit um for me was uh
quite uh
it focused quite heavily on uh
mechanical sweeping and uh and you know
and some parts of the street cleansing
without looking at some broader parts of
the service such as all the work we do
around the beaches in the summer
the 600 plus uh bins that we empty
regularly and you know
against the backdrop of what was a very
difficult couple of years through the
pandemic and the huge quantity the tons
and tons of waste additional waste that
that the the team coped with
but whilst all the time
uh having to maintain you know a
statutory service and the statutory
waste and recycling service the
household service and um you know i
think what's worthy of note is that
throughout that throughout that period
we were able to continue to deliver our
household waste service um with support
from the street cleansing service where
necessary so i think um you know i think
i'm understanding of the fact that this
that this audit is is about you know the
risk to the authority and you know and
acknowledge and accept that there's some
actions that need to be taken forward
which we will do in you know in in the
prescribed time scale um but
it it
you know the report
to me is not reflective of the
hard work and the quality of the service
that uh you know that the team provide
if i could just
yeah i mean i
certainly share
some of what you said your opinion about
the hard work
of
the of the staff i mean i've witnessed
um how hard they've had to work
certainly in my
ward
to clear a lot of fly tipping as you're
aware
around around various areas so we are
grateful for that certainly um
it just seems that the
maybe
the actual the scope for the audit may
maybe needs
to change and maybe
maybe
for more that you could comment that
you know that it doesn't seem to be
auditing
the right the right thing would that be
a quick
are you putting it
thank you councillor thank you chair
um
as as we recognizing the audit was
looking for
key controls in this process in terms of
setting the standard
delivering the service measuring the
performance and feeding that back so
that control feedback loop is a standard
process that we're looking for
which
from the findings and the bullet points
you can see uh was missing
and these are the actions that we're
you know fall into the action plan
um
so absolutely understand
the idea of looking at service delivery
but every audit is an opportunity for a
catalyst for change for improvement for
looking at different ways of achieving
things and i think we're talking about
the the the measurement
and the performance management of this
very key service it's a key corporate
objective for the council um
i absolutely agree with everything that
said in terms of you know pandemic and
resources being moved around and the
huge effort and i think it's often
difficult to understand that an audit
isn't being it's not a critical it's a
critical friend in the sense of a fresh
pair of eyes looking at things but what
we're looking for is that control
feedback loop and that clearly wasn't
here at this time and you know it's
really good news for the for this this
committee who our job is to provide that
assurance to members of this committee
that those things are working and
they're you can measure them
the tangible
um that we're hearing that the action
plan is is being dealt with and some
things are even imminent
so we would welcome the opportunity to
come back to in the future and say yep
things are embedded they're working and
and you can now rely on those internal
controls it's a slightly different thing
to um
what's actually happening out there on
the street so i do appreciate that um
but hopefully we can work together when
we scope the next audit to see what's
what's the key risk at this time and um
it isn't completely unusual it happens
where we have a service
having a different opinion um to what we
find but as you know our work is
evidence-based we've gone to look for
key things and when they're not there
then we have to report those things to
you so i hope that helps
thank you
i'm just going to institute do you want
to say something
thank you chair if i may i i really just
really want to kind of
really support the comments from both
christine and from mike and just to say
that actually you know i think it's the
whole process is quite reassuring that
actually this does provide an
opportunity because at the end of the
day internal audit have a very specific
role and add value to what we're doing
as an organization and that function is
very clear uh just to say that actually
you know and to clarify directors do
have the opportunity to agree the brief
before the audit is undertaken but
understandably at the end of the day
particularly in operational services but
not solely these are very complex
services at times there's a whole range
of contacts actually um
you know the officers feel it's
important to provide you with
reassurance that although there are some
issues that internal world are quite
rightly raising around controls and that
process that christine's uh talk talked
to us quite rightly about it's also to
provide you with reassurance that there
are reasons for that sometimes it's
resources sometimes it's just the
complexity of the service and we have to
look at it and it's just a reminder
about there's a broader perspective to
consider so i don't think it's unhealthy
to have different perspectives on this
at all i think that's what this process
is around which is why managers do get
an opportunity to provide their response
so you can see it from their perspective
but clearly you know internal audit has
a very specific and very important
function in rel in relation to making
sure that we continue to improve and
make sure we're getting these things
right so i just wanted to add that thank
you very much for letting me do that
council hopkinson
thank you chair um
yeah i mean obviously it's uh it's
clearly true but we've been operating
very difficult circumstances the last
year or two and also uh
i've no doubt it's also true the uh our
staff are working very hard and uh they
should be given credit for that um i
just wanted to ask for a clarification
on so the first the bullet point on page
24 that the lack of service standards
um so just check my understanding does
that mean that uh there aren't criteria
for measuring the success of the
delivery of the services that is that
what it means
and if that's the case um
apologies if this is in the report but
uh could you update us some if on what
what the plan is with that uh just
particularly given that it's not it's
been highlighted in previous reports
um
yes so it means uh currently that yeah
there aren't um
tdc published service standards uh uh
about uh about the level of cleanliness
and how that um you know how that links
with the uh the code of practice for for
for street cleanliness for littering
detritus um
but that's that's one of the actions in
the audit plan to you know to put that
in place
yeah yeah i would say can i just i'll
just clarify
we we did find a service standard didn't
we but
i think something it wasn't published so
i think what we just need to do is
expand on that and it's really around
what
people can expect from us and what we
expect from them as well so it's sort of
setting those standards because
obviously we do need support of local
residents as well in terms of keeping
our streets clean it's not just
our issue it's also one for all our
communities as well so so that'll be
included in that standard as well
thank you yeah yeah i mean i do agree
with that sentiment that it's uh
you know it's the community as a whole
as well as the council that's uh you
know we address it collectively um so
can i just i apologize because i'm sure
this is in the report and i've perhaps
not seen it but um so
could you give us a bit of detail about
um
you know what's the plan for
what if information exactly will be
published and how that will be published
for the uh for the public to
to uh
be informed about this
well
the service standard will
would describe the you know the
expectation that the level of
cleanliness and it will talk about how
we monitor
how yes so what what can be expected how
we will monitor it um
so
it's along those lines it's diffic
difficult to describe it in more detail
before we've uh you know before we've
finalized it but yeah it's it's it's
those sort of things it's a service
standard for what can be expected for
street cleansing
um
there is yeah uh so i believe it's uh
the order actually i think it's
september i think i'm right in in saying
um
the
yeah yeah yeah so so um
for example for for our street bins now
instead of uh
street bins just being emptied by by the
team on a on a on a sort of a
continual rotational basis
we've now got uh a nap that our team use
where they can
each time they empty the bin they record
that they empty it they record how much
waste was in the bin and it allows us to
um
you know to focus those resources better
so that uh you know they're not just
going to go into bins that may only be
half empty you know in theory they you
know
we get to a point where they only empty
those bins at the point it needs to be
emptied and so we increase the frequency
on the ones that are always full and and
decrease it on the ones that are that
have not um so that you know that's a
sort of a qr code based
um system where they they scan the bin
as they as they empty it
and i would clarify we've got a new
application as well which we're training
some of our staff to use where some of
our staff will go and take photographs
and then they'll get to grid the quality
of the the streets
and then what that would do is over
obviously six to 12 months we'll start
getting that intelligence so then we can
start focusing our
targeting our resources in areas where
we know got continual problems and
that's due to be rolled out in the next
couple of the next month or so yeah yeah
yeah i mean what we wanted to do i know
i spoke to it previously is is involve
members of the public as well but i
don't think we're ready for that because
we're conscious that they'll just say
well it doesn't meet the standards
doesn't mean the standard because they
want their streets to be absolutely
spotless dirty and that's not uh
deliverable but we've with our team
doing it we're more than and we've got
that evidence as well to show it
so any other questions on the street
cleansing bit yes council of duckworth
yeah um i agree with the engagement with
the public and on a very practical level
um a lot of work has been i'll give you
a specific example because it might be
able to be replicated elsewhere
so that's atherston road paladin bins
the removal of those seems to have been
very successful but i do think that the
problem might have moved elsewhere and
talking to residents
there's still some residents who don't
seem to have a wheelie bin or access to
one so and obviously and i've seen it if
if bin bags are being dumped
then immediately once the seagulls get
to them they're just going to be that's
going to cause a
a problem with litter and it's not
necessarily people dumping it so i think
more engagement would be good to find
out exactly who hasn't got those
bins and
it doesn't really know and the other
thing is
is perhaps charging for bins of horse
economy i don't know if somebody
somebody arrives at property moves into
one and doesn't have a bin
they phone up and they're told it costs
x amount of money
they could take the decision they can't
afford it so
um it might be a false economy it might
be something worth looking into i don't
i mean you probably need to do an
investigation to see
what the response is when people phone
up and ask for one but
it might be worth looking into to see
thank you
um
yeah i mean it just
in terms of the figures of sort of bins
we collect from about 68 000 properties
for domestic waste about 58 000 of those
properties
receive a standard fortnightly
collection so they they have a you know
a black bean a blue bin a red bag and a
food caddy so it's that it's the 10 000
properties that don't have that and the
reason i don't have those is is because
they haven't either haven't got anywhere
to store a store or bin or it's you know
it's it's flats or or or other other you
know apartments type other types of
accommodation um
you know where that's the case you know
they either have seagull proof bags or
they're on sat collections and i agree
you know we're we're in a coastal town
and and you know seagulls are a problem
and we you know that's why we have the
seagull proof bags and and try and do
everything you know encourage our
residents to only put the waste out at
the time you know
at the correct time um
yeah we do see problems where um people
uh take their waste elsewhere you know
they put the waste in street your
household wasting street bins which
obviously they shouldn't be doing and
those you know those are sort of
problems that we you know
we're aware of and you know we we can
tackle those those things with
enforcement or with education
um
in terms of charging for bins uh you
know
we can we can do that and it's you know
obviously the you know there's a cost to
the bins and you know we've got to think
about the about the budgets and the you
know you know the service is you know
obviously you know budget budgets
particularly particularly a critical
point um
under the environmental protection act
we you know we can charge for those for
those containers um for you know which
have to be presented for for waste
collection so um um you know it's a
it's something that's currently in place
to do that
um so you wanted to come here yeah just
i mean i know bob will probably confirm
we have done a lot of work with the
housing team previously with regards
it's quite a transient population in
some areas isn't it and we have done
obviously leaflets in different
languages advice about seagull proof bad
so it's just an ongoing campaign and
engaging with with the landlords as well
to make sure they're taking
responsibility not just for providing
sufficient containers but having those
containers in suitable locations where
we can get access because you know your
selfies
it's quite difficult for us sometimes
but obviously we do work with our
partners the community and the housing
team to try and resolve issues when we
when we see them come forward
i just want one small point to add to
that um
in the um
in the cliftonville section licensing
area the um
obviously that that designation has
ended now but the licenses that have
been we've issued are still valid and
for the whole five-year period
they do require the landlord to um
maintain
reasonable arrangements for the storage
of refuse for their
tenants
and
if if we can demonstrate the landlord is
not doing that then there's potential to
take enforcement action against that
licence
thank you yeah i did just want to ask
one further question he reminded me of
it
talking about
talking about enforcement there earlier
we i think we all know and acknowledge
that there is
a lot of fly tipping that causes a big
problem
i mean i'm
i'm sure it's right across the district
but where i'm familiar with
um
some peters and businesses the fly tip
in the um
bins in the car park station is
how much
how much enforcement action actually is
there i mean how many
prosecutions would you be able to tell
us how many prosecutions
there have been by the council of people
fly tipping because i know it's it's a
real concern for
the majority of businesses who do pay
to have their rubbish
um taken away
um properly
so is is there any figures available
that actually fits within a different
service area yes there are i would say
the amount of of prosecutions has
reduced dramatically over the last two
years because of the pandemic and we
know we've had issues but we do have a
team an active team out there
you might be aware i think uh two years
ago we introduced the fixed penalty
nurses for 400 pounds so actually if we
catch people fly tipping and we got
enough evidence we can issue with them
fixed penalty notice 400 pounds rather
than taking them through prosecutions
and we also in terms of if we catch
people in in in duty care issues we can
give them formal warnings and they can
pay for the cost of removal etc but
actually at this moment in time i think
we're doing a fundamental review of that
standard and actually we're going to
move that forward because one of the
issues for me particularly having some
uh previous experience in enforcement is
the time and effort he's taking us and
the resources required internally to get
to a stage six months down the line
where we're prosecuting people and what
that level of prosecution is and what
the value is to both the community and
the council in terms of that time and
effort so this is something we're
looking at in in the next few months
thank you chad
um
yeah just going back to the uh it's good
to hear about the uh technologies you're
looking to introduce um and i just
wanted some perhaps a question for the
chair um
when we when we get a chance to hear
about how they're going and uh
and the effects that's that's happening
so i just wonder when that might come
back for this committee would be the
next uh quarterly internal
audit update perhaps i don't know
i believe that be the follow-up
possibly thank you chair thank you
councillor yes the follow-up will come
forward to this committee the timing of
which is dependent upon the um dates
agreed with management for the
implementation of the recommendations
clearly one of the key ones is the
service standards i think mr humber
indicated september for that so clearly
um
there wouldn't be a great deal of merit
in bringing the
or undertaking the follow-up and
reporting it to this committee until at
least september so you're probably
looking at the end of september or the
december meeting before we could
meaningfully report back on the
follow-up
i hope that answers the question
i guess a comment from me regarding the
street cleansing is it seems that
there's almost um
similar to cancer at a different
viewpoint i think no one here is
questioning the performance it's just
more about mitigating risk in the
control measures
one of the small things is about
mechanical sweeps and i think that the
reason it's been
it's been picked up is more of a is
in terms of value for money
it's a big investment and the investment
has been going up each year and it's the
the output it hasn't been great and
you've mentioned about plans moving
forward just wondered if are any of
those going to involve more investment
and is there anything that you can do
with the mechanical sweepers so that we
do get value for money out of them
thank you
i suppose from our point of view i'm a
bit disappointed because there was a lot
of effort for me and and portfolios
at the time in terms of that investment
in mechanical tweakers because we didn't
have them it's clear that actually
the smaller mechanical sweepers haven't
worked in the district particularly in
in the environment around the coast
because of the sand it's quite uh
abrasive and it has a bit of an impact
in terms of of the
vehicles and sustaining them and and the
amount of uh repairs and maintenance
that are required so i think we actually
are at this moment in time
due to replace that fleet and we are
looking at alternatives and and really
looking at larger vehicles and also the
use of other technologies as well i
think i think
you have to appreciate and this is quite
an important point is is
we have an aging workforce and that
aging workforce and not really that
interested in in new using new types of
technology they're quite happy with the
sweepers and the barrows which is which
is fine but there is technology
available out there that we could be
utilizing and that's what we're doing as
part of that transition now
like i says we'll be looking at sort of
larger sweepers less of them but they
can cover larger areas and then looking
at alternatives in the in the streets
etc but i think it's just that balance
and and i think
what we really need to express is in and
we haven't really promoted it i don't
think as well as we could is is this
idea with regards to environmental
operatives which is a total change from
these these these are this is a
multitasking team as part of the budget
we're going to bring in some more so
we're going to have up to nine of these
environmental operatives and what they
do is they go into targeted areas
and they do a multitude of tasks so
they'll just do street cleansing they
fix furniture they fix signs they they
generally do
cut grass they do a whole range of tasks
and it provides a huge benefit to
obviously those areas and has been very
very well received and we have been
working with the town parishes etc and
they've been giving us locations and
we've gone in there i think what we've
not been good at is actually telling
people that's what we're doing but
that's part of that transition and
they're using available technology and
actually those teams are trained to use
all the technology so they can they can
ride mowers they can use sweepers they
can use
our trucks diggers etc so they can go in
and do a multi-filter task which is a
totally different way of working which
we're likely to see significant
improvements
okay and leading on to that point from
sort of a public engagement side of
things and
is there anything you can do in terms of
and it might help in terms of you
showing what you're doing to the public
but actually pre-warning residents when
you're targeting particular areas so you
know you might get more people to move
their cars out of the way and therefore
it becomes more effective it might sound
a bit timely but i'm sure you can find a
routine to do it but actually it will it
almost is a self-fulfilling possibility
to let you
show what you're doing and therefore
meredith's more aware of it because
they'll see that you've done it and
they've had the warning as well
yeah i mean the idea of the
environmental operatives came from
experience i'd had where i've worked in
a local authority where we covered a
thousand square miles
uh so actually quite a large area and
what we used to do was was sort of
targeted
uh impact uh where we'd go into certain
areas and this is part of that that
program but also what we used to do as
part of that program is work with
partners so we're with kcc in terms of
hardware so we can get them to do some
of the drainage they can do some of the
landing work also work with the
community particularly school kids so we
have the school kids coming out and
doing litter picks as well with the
communities and fixing furniture so this
is part of the conversation we've been
having with some of the the parishes and
and we're sort of moving that forward
aren't we and that'll be for me is we
can't get everywhere but i think it's
it's gonna look like probably a two-year
period
of of work where we can say we're going
to be we're going to be in this location
we'll speak to people ask them what they
need doing and then obviously ask them
to support and come out with us as well
so they can see that benefit as well
okay great thank you um are there any
questions on any of the other issues
within this report
from any members
okay well i've got a couple so i'll uh
pleasure um
regarding the playground inspections i
mentioned two of the inspectors were
operating under expired certificates
do we know how much buy and how long do
these certificates usually last
i'm afraid i haven't got that
information to hand but i can i can come
back and confirm
okay is that something that's
normally gains from once the person has
got the role or do you employ people
with i'm just thinking like if you have
a staff turnover that's a lot of admin
and cost to train them and get them
licensed yeah
so
to talk about the staff that we've
currently got they've all gained the
qualification while they've been here
while they've worked here so they did
they didn't arrive they didn't come to
the council with that qualification
um
uh next question would be i'm doing
quality and diversity training was there
any particular reason for the low take
up amongst staff to have completed this
training i'm not sure who that's going
to go to but presumably
actually presumably you there we go okay
you can fight over it if you want um
let's make it equal
oh yeah thanks very much chair um so the
equality and diversity training is
something that we're actively uh looking
at with the new hr team so we're
currently working uh with uh both online
resources and also there's somebody who
works for folkestone high district
council with expertise in this area and
we're looking at rolling out and
promoting
take up of the training as well it is
something that's been a bit lacking but
we're we're on it and dealing with it
i think just as you know and you know i
i think we completely accept and
acknowledge this i think partly this is
e-learning training
and i think as a result um this is not
an excuse at all we do need to address
it but i think because of the pandemic
the way we've been working this has
probably slipped off people's radar
quite significantly e-learning generally
and i think as part of the approach
particularly around this very important
subject i think the learning we now the
the training we're now doing i think
i've got this right haven't i estelle is
actually an actual course that we're
running that we're is compulsory for all
staff to be doing rather than the
e-learning but it's something we need to
think about in the future about how we
actually undertake this very important
training uh in respect of ourselves
especially now we're flexibly working
and whether the learning is the right
package or whether we need to think of a
different way of doing some of the
training
almost like a corporate induction kind
of yeah
new starters yeah okay um
uh on page 23
um now i got concussion at the weekend
so i do apologize if my math isn't great
um but i was looking at the table with
regards to the right to buy
um
and where it's got someone might need to
explain this but uh total applications
received where you've got 31 34 and 50.
going along where they've been broken
down um to the right the top row
actually only adds up to 17
and so i wasn't sure if there's been
some that have just randomly disappeared
um and the middle one's fine and then
the bottom one goes to 48 and not 50
which i didn't know whether those ones
were potentially live but it's just the
top one just looked a bit peculiar
i don't think we know the answer to that
i'm afraid
um but we can go away and check the
numbers for you and uh confirm yeah
perfect thank you i thought i was just
seeing things and i had to double check
it but
they definitely
okay brilliant and one small thing uh in
fact that's the next item so i won't
even comment on that um
so members any other questions
perfect uh the recommendations is that
the report is received by members and
any changes to the agreed 2021-2022
internal audit plan resulting from
changes in perceived risk detailed at
point 5.0 of annex one of the attached
report be approved can i have a proposer
and a seconder
proposed by councillor cup
and seconded by councillor dexter unless
i hear any objection i will take this as
approved
brilliant
moving on to agenda item 5 the draft
internal audit plan for 2022-23
i'll introduce you to christine parker
from east kent audit partnership
thank you chair
if i may members
before we get to discussing the plan
itself i'll just take you through the
covering report
by way of introduction
the first paragraph really is just for
you to note the important role that this
committee does play to ensure the
governance risk and control environment
is appraised um
and the other point to note at this
point is the is a strategic plan that
we're showing you multiple years but
we're only looking to agree the next 12
months program of work this evening
uh paragraph two talks about the mission
and the charter and members
who've been on the long serving on the
committee will remember the charter
would come back annually with the plan
but it was it's a document that doesn't
have many changes annually
we agreed um that the next time it would
need to come back would be uh in 2023
and i can confirm there's no significant
changes to the version so we aren't
presenting this evening it's available
at any time members need to see it
and we haven't changed the mission
in that paragraph
so moving to the process uh to date that
has formed this draft response plan
that's before you this evening
in accordance with our professional
standards there's a process behind this
and it involves multiple sort of sources
of information in terms of
looking at the corporate risk registers
looking at what we know trends
nationally and others in local
government
speaking to directors around what
systems are changing what new
legislation is impacting all the things
that are likely to be happening in their
areas
and then we take that broader view
the institute of internal auditors
survey all sectors and for the
sort of purpose of of comparing us as
well through that uh we've included the
top ten risks from that survey so the
the risks listed one to ten and
paragraph three point three onwards are
national they're certainly not uh done
risks and they're what they're broader
than local government
um they work that none of those will
surprise you of course with um cyber
um security and i think with the added
pressure with with the
international events with russia and
other matters these these things become
very very real um we're all sort of
aware of attacks on our own identity
theft and and phishing emails and other
i.t issues so it's a it's a constant
sort of issue of trying to encourage uh
educate staff and to not click on any
link
and to send things that they're not sure
about to uh to a t for for checking
through
so naturally the is kent services
element of the plan has rit provision in
there and that's part of this report
um i won't go through one to ten um in
in detail i'm sure you've read them all
but you it's really to provide you with
the assurance that we've considered them
all
and then either built them into the
proposed plan or not for the reasons
that we have given um and i think we
notice um whilst climate seems to be
sort of lower down in number eight i
think we're noticing that this is going
to be a top level risk that we live with
now for the future
we're recognizing that and obviously we
have done some work this year with
climate and we've got a further five
days there
so moving through the report in terms of
um how we then have uh assessed it in
terms of the core assurance work any
fraud work any other areas of risk that
we need to cover we cover the
benchmarking provision just so that
you've got a sense of how this plan fits
within the wider picture and i can then
further go on to commend the plan to you
the plan itself is set out on pages
53-58
and the recommendation or the options
members are to
approve the plan as drafted or very much
to take any consideration of comments
and amendments that members may wish to
make to
adjust the plan
so happy to take any comments thank you
councillor duckworth
uh yeah just on um
item 10 health and safety
um with coronavirus will um
the will they cancel be encouraging
people to
stay stay off work if they do have
covered symptoms even though it's no
longer a legal requirement
uh thank you chair um in respect of
covid19 we're we're now moving to a
position where covid19 will be treated
uh
in respect of normal sickness absence so
if an individual member of staff has
symptoms for covid we would be expecting
them if they are ill not to be at work
and to follow our sickness absence
process and to actually register that
sickness through our system that's how
we will be intended to deal with it
thank you
any other questions from members
no and christine on
paragraph
six financial resilience
um page 49 um says mtpf is that meant to
be mtfp
um
the recommendation is to well
members approve the council's internal
audit plan um please can have a proposer
and a seconder
proposed by councillor duckworth and
second div by councillor shrub
unless i hear any objection i take this
as approved
perfect
moving on to agenda item 6 corporate
risk management the quarterly updates i
will now call upon mr blundell to
introduce the review of corporate risks
thank you chair good evening members
this is our regular updates on our
approach to risk management
setting out the highest score on
corporate risks that the authority is
considering they're set out on the table
on section four of the report and then
there's further detail in section five
to explain what the reports are uh in
the report to set up what those risks
are
you'll see in the table at 4.2 the only
change from the previous report that
came to the committee
last time around is a reduced risk for
coping 19 largely reflecting the end of
restrictions and the explanation the
chief executive just gave in terms of
how we'll be treating sickness absence
in relation to
copic 19.
aside from some the scores not changing
there are just some other
things i'd like to just bring attention
to it has already been referenced
already in terms of cyber attack
by
christine parker obviously the events in
ukraine are at the forefront of
management's mind and we will be
considering an item on
not just cyber insurance but other
measures we can take to
protect ourselves and bolster our
defenses and that we come to our
corporate management team in the coming
weeks
and our itt
and digital teams are looking at that
actively there's an update obviously
where we are in terms of governance
although the scores haven't changed the
members will be aware of the
the update that the external independent
monitoring officer has given initially
to our general purpose committee and
that's explained in the report
over and above that there is
an
an update on unlimited resources it's
very pleasing obviously the budget was
approved at uh council last month
however as it's set out i've said it on
the report and i've said on a number of
occasions the
funding landscape for local government
still remains very uncertain and that's
reflected in the risk score
and again economic resources uh sets out
the an unchanged school it's not just
brexit and covert but we're aware
obviously the turbulent times in the
economy inflation is very high and there
are disturbances in the supply chain uh
across um across the the economy and
that's something we are we're monitoring
and continue to try and manage
be that through
market supplements or other measures
that we need to take
in addition to the risks to set out the
report annex one provides some details
of the lower scoring risks as previously
requested by the committee and just in
terms of a verbal update for reference
we're currently working on a new risk
management strategy that went through
our corporate management team this week
and i'll be bringing this
next meeting of the committee for
feedback and input
and for further review and comments so
uh happy to take any further questions
members have on the content of this
report thank you
councillor duckworth
um yeah just a quick one um
the
cabinet risk champion i think it's the
wrong portfolio title i know they do
change quite often um so that's page 67
3.5
i don't think i think it might be the
leader actually
might be within the leaders um portfolio
but there isn't a corporate in
governance and coastal development
correct i think that's just something
that's that's the legacy that's not been
updated for a change in transparency
thank you yes we'll get that updated
councilor garner
thank you
yeah i mean we're we're used to um
come to this point of the agenda i think
and seeing
um read all over the all over the report
um
some of the some of these risks some of
these areas obviously are out of our
control
um but some of them are within our
control so those are within our control
how
confident are we that we will
come to one of these meetings and see a
a reduction in
in any of these areas do we have
do we have a cogent plan for some of
these areas that i know there is some
some um description of how we of what's
happening with them but you know what
sort of time scales are we talking to
it would be nice if it wasn't all read
at one of the meetings
um i think that's an entirely valid
question and i think probably the the
items that we we
potentially have some control over as an
organization that we would be looking to
see some change in and probably those
are
obviously going to be impacted by the
outcome of the independent monitoring
officers report
which i would anticipate is certainly
going to reflect how we move forward
around the governance and reassurance
around that i think political
stewardship is something that we'll be
we we've talked about already reviewing
so i i would anticipate that changing in
due course
um i think um i don't know about
homelessness i mean that's still a big
issue so i think we probably think
that's probably going to stay
red at the moment um covered 19 i think
you know we'd still need to manage that
risk in the sense of
it still exists will we get any other
variants that we then have to deal with
but
uh on the basis of the approach that
government are currently taking about
learning to live with it i think
probably we should see a reduction
in that risk because we should have
mitigated and controls and plans in
place for managing that so the
environmental act is a bit of an unknown
quantity at the moment still but um but
yeah i think certainly over the next six
months we'd probably expect to see some
change in some of those those numbers
on that
chris i don't know about anything um
just about that there are obviously
other risks that aren't included in this
of
this table the reason the there's red
all over it is that we tend to bring the
well we present the highest scoring
wrists which are scored red
um
some of them will drop down as the chief
exec said it through the the passage of
time and um
as those those risks develop and we get
a better understanding of uh what action
we need to take to mitigate them
but our risk management strategy is uh
the update to it's proposing a slightly
different approach a bit more nuanced
where we'll be categorising some of our
risks in a different way as well not
saying that not saying that will
effectively
uh change the scoring there'll probably
still be
a large degree in red here but hopefully
a bit more nuance in there to give you
more detailed information around the
nature of the risk and the actions that
have been taken to mitigate them
something something that that sort of
jumped out of me under cyber attack
um
it
you've mentioned the recent attempts to
send emails to staff
from internal email addresses
such as the chief executives i don't
know if you've got any
well what exactly has happened
they are um in terms of this specific
one that they are
fishing
attempts or other
attempts where someone will attempt to
present themselves as a tdc officer in
this instance as the chief executive and
send a message around saying please
click this link because of xyz i can't
remember the specifics of this but that
it's it's not just uh limited to that
instance there and this is obviously not
just limited to thanic district council
this is tactics that fraudsters and and
cyber attackers
undertake across um all areas of society
and
and something that is we're trying our
best to protect ourselves against but
unfortunately these cyber attackers are
very skillful and it's a developing
sort of
picture as they develop their skills we
have to have to react in a responsive
sort of manner to as their tactics and
their approaches change
councillor hopkinson
thank you um i just wanted to ask for a
slight clarification because i assume
that political stewardship refers to
you know balance of power amongst the
different political groups in the
chamber i don't know if i misunderstood
but were you not implying that
this is somehow under sort of management
uh it's there isn't something that can
be done about it other than
you know the next election basically
well i think uh what we've already
identified is currently um obviously we
have a conservative i think it's been a
number of changes administration as part
of this uh for the last period since the
last election you're right we are
entering an election year for our local
elections in in 2023 but i think the
longer the current administration is in
place and uh obviously part of that is
around kind of the numbers position
around
party party numbers then i think from
that we gain
more uh sustainability and stability as
a result of that so the longer that goes
on
then that risk obviously starts to
reduce
that's that's the approach that we take
kind of to the political it's i mean the
current uh scoring of that does reflect
the fact that we have been through a
number of changes over the last few
years in respect of administration and
and party numbers but the more that
remains consistent and improves then
obviously that stability can be
established and that risk comes down
okay
but you're right we've got an election
coming so i'm sure we'll we'll see what
happens as a result of that as well
are there any other comments or
questions from members
okay i'll move the recommendation which
is to consider the corporate risks
identified in the report to consider the
effectiveness of the authority's risk
management arrangements and the control
environment and consider their assurance
with the action that is being taken on
risk-related
issues please can have a proposal and a
seconder
proposed by councillor cup
seconded by councillor hopkinson unless
i hear any objection i will take this as
approved
great
moving on to agenda item seven and back
to chris brondell for the statement of
accounts update
thank you chair this is a multi-faceted
report
relating to last year's this year's and
next year's accounts and audits
providing an update on where we are with
those
um firstly then so the
last year's 2021 accounts that are
currently being audited
typically they would have come to a
committee already to be approved and we
would hoped actually that they would
have come tonight for approval however
despite the fact the order is largely
complete there are still two critical
judgment items that need to be
determined and resolved we're a couple
of weeks away from getting that done um
so with the um
chair chairman's uh chairs agreement my
apology chairs agreement we'll be
looking to arrange a
uh meeting sometime in may most likely
to prove the account so we're not
waiting um to the next scheduled meeting
so we get the accounts approved as soon
as possible
looking towards the the next year's
account so for 21 22
the same deadlines are still in place as
the current year so draft accounts by
the first of august will need to be
published which we hit last year and
auditors accounts um finalized by 30th
of september however only nine percent
of audits were actually done by that
thirty percent of um
nine percent of audits apologies put my
teeth back in nine percent of audits
were finished by the 30 for september
deadline
so we're not alone and that uh stats not
improved uh drastically only 40 by the
end of december
that has then
led sit for to launch an emergency
sounds rather exciting but it's not as
exciting as it sounds an emergency
consultation on changes to accounting
standards that's how we like to excite
ourselves as accountants talking about
emergency consultations to accounting
standards um we've provided a response
to that consultation it's not going to
affect us significantly because we've
already done a large proportion of the
work and that's sent out at annex one to
honestly it's just me having a bit of a
rant at siffer and the standard setters
so um feel free to have a look at that
and comment if you wish
um my general observation of it is
they've missed the points it's not
really an issue with the standards it's
just a condition of the the state of the
audit market at the moment it's a real
issue of why we're not getting the
audits completed in other words there's
not enough audit firms out there doing
it and there's not enough auditors
available to do the audits
finally in terms of this report looking
for the accounting policies for next
year
they're included as an annex for the
committee's approval but there's no
change from uh this year's partly as a
result of that emergency consultation
so um not anything hugely exciting in
there but again something for the
committee to approve because they become
effective from the first of april
happy to take any questions
any questions or comments
nope it was obviously too exciting chris
you've all stunned them all um so moving
on to the recommendations uh one that
the committee notes the progress with
the audit of the 2020-21 statement of
accounts that the committee notes the
statutory audit deadlines for
2021-22 the committee notes the
council's response to the consultation
on the time limited changes to the code
of practice on local authority
accounting as set out in annex 1 and
that the committee approves the
2022-23 accounting policies as set out
in annex 2 of this report
please now i have a proposer and a
seconder proposed by councillor schop
and seconded by councillor duckworth
unless i hear any objection i will take
this as approved
perfect uh back to chris plum blundell
for agenda item eight it is the 2021-22
waivers
thank you chair uh hopefully an item of
a bit more interest this time around
rather than just accounting standards
updates so i'm hoping this will be the
first of many regular updates to the
committee on the use of procurement
waivers so the report sets out some
context on how our procurement system
works here at thanet and the framework
that's in place and that's detailed on
our contract standing orders
section three of the report sets out how
the default position for our procurement
process is really to put contracts out
into uh the
competitive bidding arena and then
tables one and two set out the
difference limits that are in place and
the different methods that follow
depending on the value and the type of
contract it is obviously the more
detailed processes are understandably
required for higher value contracts
following on from that section four
explains how if a contracting manager so
typically a budget holder wants to
deviate from our standard processes uh
and the methods are in place for
procurement that a waiver must be
obtained and there's a
some circumstances that this can be
applied and they're explained in the
report
finally moving on to section six which
sets out the actual uh incidence and
number of waivers that have been applied
and approved in 21 22.
first off i just want to
yeah apologize there's a typo in the
table i'm not looking into the future
it refers the 18th of september 2022
that should be 18th of february
but you you can see there have been 45
waivers approved in the year to date
uh of which uh three were rejected a
total of 48. you see the vast majority
of them are actually for lower value so
less than 100 000 contracts and that's
the actual value of the contract over
the duration of its life not the annual
spend
happy to take any questions
counselor ghana
yeah i think so thank you i think
something that would help would actually
be
um
to understand
what the situation is
with waivers in other
um district councils in east kent that
would help to give us an idea of with if
is this sort of an extraordinarily high
number extraordinary no low number or is
this sort of thing that that
you know
goes on in dover and canterbury and
foxton high
please
that's something with something we can
look at um i need to see
what's published in terms of their
information uh i'm not sure off uh
offhand
the the general rule is
as i kind of said waivers should be
exceptional um because we should go out
to the co to the market however there
are valid reasons why we would use
waivers in some instances for example um
some of them may just be we've gone out
to the market our contract standing
orders say that we need three bidders to
come back and only two have replied so
we've got to instead of going back out
again with slightly different
um
specification or requirements we say
well that's that's satisfactory and
that's good enough or it may be because
there's a specialized nature of a
particular type of contract we've got uh
continuity with the um existing supply
and we know it will provide best value
to use them so the underlying reason
really
why you would use a waiver is because to
deviate from going out to the market we
can demonstrate we're getting value for
money um but i i hear what you're saying
around the context of what is good what
is normal um obviously there's no
thin you know we're not the same size or
the set got the same uh makeup as as
either neighboring authorities but it's
something we can look at to try and add
some context
oh good sorry if i could
wouldn't
yeah because i assume
i would assume that they would be very
similar because you know if if you need
two or three
um
competitive bids for each one and we
we're not able to find two or three then
it would be the same in neighbouring
districts that's fair common um the one
caveat i've added to that obviously we
have uh in-house
direct
services for the likes of waste
collection street cleansing where some
of those services would be outsourced
under one contract so obviously there's
that you've almost disaggregate to a
larger number of contracts because we're
dealing with the operation of those
services directly
obviously and bringing even if you could
look at trends bringing in the likes of
our
tenant and leaseholder services would
bring in the scope for more waivers and
that doesn't mean we're doing worse
because we've got more than last year
but in context we've got more direct
control over our spend which gives
greater opportunity for waivers but i'll
do what i can to provide meaningful and
fair comparison but i don't want to um
set us up uh uh with a with an unfair
comparison against other authorities
that aren't in the same
sort of situation as us
yeah i do i mean i guess we want i mean
the key word you mentioned around waves
is exceptional
so
it's not it's some we have i can see
there has been a slight reduction over
the last three years which is a good
thing so we would want to be working
towards further reductions in the use of
waivers
wouldn't we i'm just seeking
confirmation in that i think that's a
fair observation
um but i wouldn't want to have some sort
of arbitrary uh target set that says oh
we're only we're only aiming for 30
waivers no year is typical i mean and
particularly we may see an uptick in in
waivers because we've got a huge capital
programme over the next couple of years
to deliver the leveling up funds and
that there may be circumstances where
waivers will need to be um applied and
approved because that will provide value
for money i think they should be
exceptional but the under um
the the underlying reason a rationale
for approving a waiver should be that
doing that and deviating from our
standing processes provides value for
money for the council and for uh uh for
council taxpayers and i think the
purpose of this report is to demonstrate
not only how often we're doing this but
within the annex there's a reason for
that and so you can see that the the
rationale set out and that we are even
if we're deviating from
set processes by doing so we're offering
value for money to the council
councillor hopkinson
thank you um
i just want to if you have to excuse my
arguments but i just want to check my
understanding of a waiver mean does it
mean that um the conditions that set out
in the tables but on page 101
would would not apply for a particular
purchase
thank you and then and also
just the minor point really but the page
in one the table and page 102
um i just wonder if you know if if that
was presented as a percentage of the
total purchases then that might because
you you keep referring to you know the
idea yeah it should be exceptional
so that might help us to sort of see
that
i think that's very good observation and
that perhaps could be a better um
uh comparison rather than uh against
other authorities uh to give an idea of
how much of our spend is um waived in
totality uh in terms of overall spend so
yeah we can look to add that to the next
report as well
any other questions
counselor duckworth
not really a question but um i just like
to speak in favor of waivers
because
having worked on margate tandy and i
know they're really quite important
though it's possible and looking through
the table is always done for very good
reasons so it just helps us get on with
things and central government often give
give you ridiculous time scales in which
to do things and so it's really
important
perfect
unless there's any questions or comments
the recommendation is the committee
notes the report would win would like to
note the report
great
moving on to the gender item 9 local
code of corporate governance i'll
introduce you to estelle culligan
director of law and democracy who will
introduce this report
thanks very much chair good evening
members
so this is a report to update the local
code of corporate governance which is
one of our suite of governance documents
it's referred to in the annual
governance statement and was last
updated in 2019 i think it should be
reviewed and updated regularly so this
is that update
the report and annex where you'll find
the documents reflects the sipfer and
solace good governance framework for
local government 2016 document
which sets out seven principles a to g
of good governance and those are the
headings in the document and they
require councils to provide evidence to
demonstrate those seven principles it's
quite a lot of information in the
document and it does show that we as a
council are doing lots of good things
re-governance as well as reflecting the
work still to do due to the statutory
recommendations that we've received
so where previously the code was only
accessible through a link on the annual
governance statement
the intention is to publish this
document as a standalone document
together with the annual governance
statement on the council's governance
page and therefore it will be more
easily accessible and also promotes our
obligation towards transparency of all
these issues
so that's it the report is for
noting and approving i think
and unless anybody has any questions
well if you do i'm very happy to answer
them
counselor duckworth
uh
yeah on page 140
um i struggle to understand
um
it's the bit about the recognized trade
unions and i think the reason i
struggled to understand it was because
there should be some commas in there um
it was i'll go to it and then i'll tell
you exactly where
sorry
counselor because i'm not on mod gov i'm
on the um because i i can't get it to it
so if you tell me which section it's
under b or c or
um
i see what i mean
engage with the recognized unions
through employee council and more
informal meetings
now i think it actually means engagement
with the recognized unions through
employee council because we do engage
with them through employee council and
also
can you tell me a bit more about that
um the organiser the organisation the
council has regular
meetings with union representatives and
their court and we entitled them
employee council
so that's the name of the meeting that
we have regularly with the union
representatives both from gmb and unison
all right
it's the name of the meeting the
itself is called employee council but
who sits on employee council is the
union representatives both regional and
our own local representatives and the
approach i sit on there along with an hr
uh
officer and we often have our finance
colleagues coming along as well because
often we're talking about budget
implications so that that meeting talks
about things that generally impact on
staff and we use that as a forum with
which to negotiate with unions or inform
union representatives
i think we have separate ones with each
of the representative unions so several
one with gmb and then a separate one
with unison in its position
it can be when we're talking about the
pay award yeah that's that's how that's
the process we follow perspective of
that
uh council hopkinson
thank you yeah so can i just clarify
them so that means that you don't
negotiate with um more than one union
jointly at the same time it's always
it's always done separately one union at
a time
um we have the discussions with both
representatives at that meeting but then
the unions go off and meet with their
respective members consult with their
respective members and then feedback
separately
the the outcome of those kind of
discussions they've had with their with
their unions so they are separate union
activities but they come together as
part of the employee council we use that
one meeting in which to share what the
council's policy around a range of staff
activities whether it's staffing
policies or whether it's to do with the
annual pay award we have that discussion
initially at that meeting at the
employee council then those union
representatives go off and consult with
their members and then feedback
does that is that clarify thank you
are there any other questions or
comments from members
okay the recommendation is that the
committee adopts the revised local code
of corporate governance for
2021
um
for jubilee 2021 should be 2022
it's
twenty
true
no it's twenty twenty two yeah so twenty
twenty two apologies
okay
um please can i have a proposal and a
seconder proposed by council hopkinson
seconded by councillor duckworth thank
you unless i hear any objection i will
take this as approved
great
moving on to agenda item 10 annual
governance statement 2021-20
action plan update um i'll send you back
to estelle culligan who will present
this report
thanks very much chair so this is very
brief report it's a regular update on
where we are with the progress of the
action plan for this year set out in the
annual government statement which we
published in early january haven't been
approved in december
the report and the update is
self-explanatory is fairly brief the
main issues to note are of course
reference to the statutory
recommendations the updates to the
financial procedure rules which have
been um successfully carried out by mr
blundell and his team and the most
recent updates that we've had to the
constitution so it's very
straightforward
do members have any comments to make
great the recommendation of the
committee is asked to note the reports
would members please note the report
perfect
moving on to agenda item 11 chairs
annual report to council
it says here hopefully you read my
annual report to governance and audit
committee add any comments you might
like
yeah i'm fine
do any members of the only members of
the panel have any questions
that gets me off the hook would members
please note the report
thank you
agenda item 12 is the exclusion of
public and press
i move that the public and press be
excluded for the meeting for agenda item
13 as it contains exempt information as
defined in paragraphs one two three and
seven of part one of